i've got a handful of matrices here i
have the matrix a that's an m by n
matrix you can see it has n columns and
m rows and actually let me throw in one
entry there it might be useful this is
the this is the jth column so the nth
row is going to look like this amj
that's that entry right there and then i
have matrix b defined similarly but
instead of being an m by n matrix b is
an n
by m matrix and so this entry right here
let me just
i might i realize this might be useful
this is going to be my nth row and it's
going to be my jth column and then i
also wrote out their transposes so if
you look at the transpose of b b was an
n by m matrix now the transpose is going
to be an m
by n matrix and each of its rows become
its columns and the same thing i did for
a
its transpose is right there a was m by
n the transpose is n by m
and each of these rows become each of
these columns now fair enough let's
define two new matrices right now let's
define the matrix c
let's define the matrix c let me do it
over here where let me do it over here i
think the real estate will be valuable
in this video
let's define my matrix c as being equal
to the product of a and
b so what's what are going to be the
dimensions of c well m by n matrix times
an n by m matrix these two have to be
equal even for the matrix matrix product
to be defined it's going to result with
an m by m matrix so it's going to be an
m by m matrix now let's define another
matrix let's call it d
d
and it's equal to
b transpose
b transpose times a
transpose
and the dimensions are going to be the
same because this is an m by n times an
n by m so these are the same which is a
requirement for this product to be
defined and so the dimensions of b are
going to be m
by m m
by m
so let's explore a little bit what the
different entries of c are going to look
like so let me write my matrix c right
here
so it's just going to have a bunch of
entries c 1 1 c 2 2 c 1 2 all the way to
c
1 m you could imagine it's just an m by
m matrix you have c m m over here you
know how to you know how this drill goes
but what i'm curious about is how do we
figure out what c
the general c i j is how do we figure
out
what a particular entry is we know that
c is the products of a and b so to get
to a particular entry in c and we've
seen this before so it's a particular
entry in c so c
i j
it's going to be you can view it as the
dot product of the i throw in a
the i-th row in a
with the j-th column in b
just like that
and what's that going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to a i 1
a i 1
times b 1 j
b 1 j
plus a i 2
a i 2 x b 2 j
b 2 j and you're just gonna keep going
until you get to the last term here a i
n
a i n times the last term here b and j
b and j
fair enough
now what about our matrix d what are its
entries going to look like
so d similarly
it's going to look like you know you're
going to have d11 d12 sorry
d12 all the way to d1
m you're gonna have dmm i could keep
putting entries here but i'm curious
about just that some general entry here
let's say i want to find
d
sub j
i
d sub j i that's what i want to find so
i want to find a general way for any
particular entry of d the j
row and ice column which is a little bit
different than the convention we
normally use for these letters but it's
fine
the first one is d's row the second one
is these is this entries column so how
do we figure that out so d
sub j
i
it's going to be equal to d is the
product of these two guys so to get the
jth row and ith column entry here we
essentially take the dot product of the
jth row here
so we're going to take the dot product
of the jth row here
which is that right there
with the ith column of a
which is that right there so i'm going
to take the dot product of that and you
might already see something interesting
here
this thing right here is equivalent to
that thing right there and this thing
right here is equivalent to that thing
right there because we took the
transposes but let's actually just
write it out
so what is this dot product going to be
equal to
what's going to be b i j let me write it
this way it's going to be b i j times a
i 1 or we could write it as a
i 1 x b
1 j and it's going to be plus b 2 j
times a i 2 which is the same thing as a
i 2 times b 2 j a i 2 times b
2 j and you're going to keep going until
you get b n j
times
a i n or you could write that as
a i n
times b and j
b and j
now notice something these two things
are equivalent they're completely
equivalent statement the d sub j i is
equivalent to c sub i j let me write
that
so d
or i could write c sub i j is equivalent
to
d
sub j
i
or another way you could say it is
anything that's at row all the entries
that's at row i
column j in c
is now in
row j column i
in d and this is true for all the
entries
true
for
all entries i stayed as general as
possible so what does this mean this is
the definition of a transpose
so we now get that c
c transpose is equal to d or you could
say that
c is equal to d transpose now this is
pretty interesting because how did we
define these two
we said
that our matrix c
is equal to our matrices matrix the
matrix product a and b and we said that
d is equal to our matrix product b
transpose times a transpose
i did those those definitions right
there
here are the definitions
now we just found out that d
is equal to the transpose of c
so we could write that c transpose which
is the same thing as a times b
transpose
is equal to d
so it is equal to d which is just b
transpose
a transpose and this is a pretty neat
takeaway
this is a pretty neat takeaway here
if i take the product of two matrices
and then transpose it it's equivalent to
switching the order and or transposing
them and then taking the product of the
reversed order b transpose
a transpose
which is a pretty pretty neat takeaway
and you can actually extend this to an
arbitrary number of matrices that you're
taking the product of if you're taking
i'm not proving it here but it's
actually a very simple extension from
this right now if you take the matrixes
let's say a
let me do a different different letters
x
y
z
take their product and then transpose it
it's equal to z transpose y transpose
x
transpose i haven't proven this general
case and you could keep doing it with
four or five or n matrices multiplied by
each other but it it generally works and
you could essentially prove it using
what we proved in this video right here
that you take the product of two
matrices take the transpose it's equal
to the product of their transposes in
reverse order